i mean my first drug wasn't [ __ ] weed
or cigarettes or alcohol like a normal
kid my first drug was
slamming [ __ ] heroin like i didn't
even smoke it
at nine
all right scooter scooter uh where'd you
grow up where you from
originally sacramento
sacramento california and tell me about
how you grew up yet uh
i grew up in venice and this is a very
like
you grew up in venice yeah i was born in
sacramento though
and actually i grew up in roseville
sorry i moved to venice oh
probably when i was 16 more like ran
away with my girlfriend
um she ended up being my wife and stuff
uh i was in the foster care system my
entire life man
and it like it sucks but it was uh
but it was um
you went to the foster system at what
age two and a half
oh what do you think what do you think
your parents lost you
i know what my mom did because she
valued drugs after she fell
there over me and then
like it sucks saying this but like i
understand why
just like drugs completely in them way
every
ounce of pain there is to be had
you know
how did you describe your childhood very
unique my parents
which are the people who took care of me
not the people who birthed me so like my
foster parents
they were gay you know i had two
homosexual men for
uh dads um i have nothing against gay
people
i love them that like they're awesome
people man
but i've had a very uh
traumatic childhood with like traumas
and
getting [ __ ] in a hostage situation
and i got shot in the head by a straight
cot bullet
i have a titanium plate there now
huh um what kind of stuff was going on
at home that
you would call it traumatic um
parents never really like
[Music]
unless word parents were
and nothing i did was good enough
everything i did was wrong
like um
i don't know i i brushed my teeth the
wrong way my tongue first and my
my fronts normally and then do my tongue
again i'd get bitched out for something
like that
for hours i'd get wine bottles thrown at
me
um
my parents used to literally take
everything out of my room except the box
frame
i mostly had a box frame my entire
channel my entire childhood
you made it through high school yeah i
actually made it through college man
my mom was uh
not my mom sorry um my parents
weren't even happy for me when i got a
girlfriend
you know i only dated one girl
and i still have only dated one girl
um and she passed away along with like
my kid
due to a drunk driver man i'm sorry
and i have to like
wake up every morning looking at myself
saying i'm like thinking
to myself that i'm not mad i wasn't man
i have to save the man
like i'm lost
you know i found myself in being a
father
long ago did this happen to your
girlfriend six months ago
this wouldn't like you really
like all you can do now is to think okay
hi
it's one thing losing your family is one
thing holding them telling them that
everything's coming you're right when
you know it's not
you know that they're just gonna die
but you can't tell him that you can't
tell
your loved ones that you
you don't want the last thing they see
is a hysterical face
the last thing them to see is just
smiling
warm warmth
today you're are you living on skid row
um
i'm really just walking around until
i go to sleep and i do it again and walk
around
around the city i don't have a solid
place to
lay my head because like if i do then
everything of mine gets stolen
i had two cars man
i mean for [ __ ] sake i have my
licensing to be a [ __ ] chiropractor
you know
but
my only desire is to just avoid
what happened you know
and i think i'm still in shock man
so you're smoking fentanyl now i slammed
it mainly
but okay and that started when
oh i've been doing fentanyl and heroin
and
opiates since i was nine years old
mom got me into and i'm smoking them
actually when i was nine
um when i was nine
i was super depressed too i was had
what's called reactive attachment
disorder or rad
i have
bipolar 1 which is manic depression
and i have odd which is oppositional
defiance disorder so like
literally everything i did was just
causing me pain and it was my fault but
like at the same time
i couldn't help i i couldn't not do it
you know
it was like i have no i had no income
impulse control until that
you know and like i became super
super depressed when i got shot in the
head and i was [ __ ]
a worried hard for years man
you feel like the drug addiction
well of course it came from your mom but
is it also hereditary
i think it the
the taste where it came from my mom but
the actual addiction itself came from
my own doing
so your adopted parents
had you but you you were back with your
mom when you were nine
so how did she introduce you to that uh
facebook we
like somehow like got in contact and
we got hot so you you were communicating
with her through facebook and then you
connected yeah and that was the worst
decision of my life that kick started me
into
drugs i mean my first drug wasn't
[ __ ] weed
or cigarettes or alcohol like a normal
kid my first drug was
slamming [ __ ] heroin like i didn't
even smoke it
at nine
it wasn't it wasn't even like a lot
like my mom knew what she was doing with
drugs just the right amount
to make me like them you know not to
give me a bad eye
but at the point where she gave me the
um heroin and [ __ ]
i was on painkillers for like my head
you know
your girlfriend that you lost she ended
up being my fiance
fiance she was also using no
she was clean mm-hmm i call her my
tether
like my little thread
she keeps me grounded man even when
she's gone
she always tells me to do the right
decision
and today you're you're friends you're
just alone wandering the streets
i have no friends friends just [ __ ]
take [ __ ] from you
they just like to use you there's no
like
hey man how's your day going
i mean by let me buy you something to
drink you know or
hey let's let's let's go let's go on the
top of a [ __ ] parking garage and just
sit and watch the sunset and we're
sunrise and like
talk deeply you know it's
yeah you got any drugs man let me get
some
or what do you want me to steal for you
to get drugs you know
or hey man i just
stole this car i just stole this
motorcycle
this trade you know
what do you worry about now
what are you afraid of
living i'm afraid of living
i am terrified of living and
nothing else
did the loss of your fiance kind of send
you in this and your child
send you in the spiral
it really didn't were there medications
for your
the bipolar disorder and other um i
i didn't take any medications my parents
didn't believe in that [ __ ]
so you never took the medications were
you ever prescribed even
no no
you know
do you have hope of getting your life
together and straightening you out or
are you just kind of waiting to
i'm just kind of waiting to die honestly
how old are you now 22. you're 22.
you're still a kid
if you were offered help to try to find
a drug program or housing or anything
like that
is that something you'd be open to or i
would 100
be willing to do housing but i can't
get rid of drugs man i
the pain and knowing i wasn't man enough
to save my
family what do you feel like it was up
to you to save them what was the
situation
because i could have pushed them out the
way but i froze
what was how did they pass away
the drunk driver ran them over when we
were just walking the roof again
carl's jr for a [ __ ] milkshake and
that's like the got on his troop
i held him in my arms as they were
breathing
and then they weren't
you feel like you could have i feel like
i could have like not frozen and be a
little [ __ ]
but i really don't want to talk about
that
anymore okay sorry
i mean without therapy that that could
be a heavy weight on your shoulders
forever though
scooter what would you say is the most
important thing you've learned in your
22 years
don't take anybody for granted even if
they enjoy the living [ __ ] at you and
every breath
is a blessing
and think about that person on the
sidewalk asking for change man
there could be someone in your family
someday you know
and you don't want people to throw
cups and like trash at them
you know we're all we're all human man
we all bleed the same blood
you know
all right scooter thank you for coming
in and sharing your story
i'll give you some places that can give
you help if you're open to it
thank you thank you
you